Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich bin Markus. Ich moderiere das Chaosradio und das wird heute hier nicht in der ursprünglichen Form stattfinden, denn heute werden hier im Chaosradio feed wie der dicke Bretter gebohrt, zum zweiten und sicherlich auch nicht zum letzten Mal. In dicke Bretter soll erklärt werden, wie Gesetze und politische Initiativen zu digitalen Themen entstehen und wie Institutionen arbeiten, in denen Regeln, Urteile oder auch Regulierungen gemacht werden. Man könnte sagen, während das Chaosradio oft genug fragt, wer hat jetzt schon wieder genau was angezündet und wie löschen wir das, geht es in dicke Bretter eher darum, wer eigentlich die ganze Zeit Holz produziert und feinsäuberlich zu Scheiterhaufen aufstapelt. Dicke Bretter ist ein Podcast in Kooperation mit netzpolitik.org von und mit Elisa Lindinger, Elina Eickstädt und Constanze Kurz, der vom Chaosradio-Team produziert wurde. Aber genug von mir. Ich verschwinde jetzt wieder und wünsche euch viel Spaß mit dicke Bretter.
Genau, und das ist vielleicht auch noch mal interessant, zu den Drahtberichten zu sagen. Wenn man so einen Drahtbericht vorliegen hat, dann würde man vielleicht denken, cool, das ist total vollständig und dann hat man einen guten Blick. In einem deutschen Drahtbericht wird halt immer drin stehen, Deutschland hat sich beteiligt wie angewiesen.
Also es lohnt sich mal, Drahtberichte zu lesen. Ich kann ja mal kurz Werbung machen auf netzpolitik.org, wo ich zufällig arbeite. Da haben wir einige der Drahtberichte, aber auch sonst Drahtberichte. Und die sind interessant, weil sie auch wieder eine Zusammenfassung der Positionen sind. Die sind auch nicht eben ausführlich oder lang.
Und was auch ganz furchtbar ist, dass die deutschen Leute in ihren Drahtberichten andere Länderkürze benutzen, als die, die international funktionieren. Das hat bei uns schon intern total viel Verwirrung gesorgt, weil ich manchmal dann die Kürze durcheinander schmeiße, wenn ich gerade so einen Drahtbericht zusammenfasse. Die sind halt auf Deutsch die Drahtberichte. Das heißt, wenn Netzpolitik sich nicht netterweise übersetzt, dann schreibe ich englische Zusammenfassungen für meine Kollegen in Brüssel teilweise, damit wir halt irgendwie ein vollständiges Tracking der Position im Rat haben. Und das kann zu sehr großer Verwirrung führen. Und wir versuchen dann halt auch immer noch an Drahtberichte von anderen Ländern zu kommen, um rauszufinden, wie Deutschland sich denn jetzt wirklich verhalten hat. Weil das ist für uns ja dann meistens das Interessante. Und das steht halt in den deutschen Drahtberichten einfach nicht drin.
Also jedes Land hat ja im Prinzip so einen Drahtbericht. Wobei, sag ich mal, ich weiß zumindest von einigen der anderen Länder, dass die unterschiedlich lang ausfallen und so. Aber das ist auch noch eine Ebene, die wäre ja eine klassische Kritik wert. Das hat der Bereich, der opark ist, auch wenn man daran mitwirken will. Aber eben ein entscheidender Bereich, denn da findet eben auch in großem Maße politische Meinungsbildung statt.
Und das ist vielleicht auch noch was, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, dass es schwer Schattenberichterstatter für Ausschüsse rauszubekommen, die nicht die federführenden Ausschüsse sind. Es ist auch sehr schwer, rauszufinden, wer die permanenten Repräsentanten, die im Rat daran arbeiten sind. Das ist wirklich, das ist so Scheller-Cohle-Level 120, das rauszubekommen und dann, wenn man den Namen rausbekommen hat, rauszufinden, wie man irgendwelche Kontaktdaten von denen kommt.
Und die sind ja auch keine Abgeordneten oder Mitarbeiter von Abgeordneten, sondern Beamte.
Das sind halt einfach Beamten und da muss man echt Glück haben und irgendwie Netzwerkeffekte nutzen. Die sind dann aber manchmal tatsächlich doch auch bereit zu reden. Am Ende des Tages wird man sie aber nicht umstimmen können, das muss man halt auch immer sagen, weil die sind halt weisungsgebunden an das, was die Regierungen sagen. Und jetzt kommen wir...
Ich denke, wir lassen den Trilog weg. Weil wir sind, also ich glaube, wir schaffen nicht mehr, wir müssen eigentlich über den Trilog reden, weil der Trilog immer eine Rolle spielt, aber bei der Chatkontrolle, die wir jetzt als Beispiel haben, da sind wir noch gar nicht so. Und dann würden wir doch einfach sagen, wir vertragen uns. Denn der Trilog ist auch in anderen EU-Gesetzgebungsprozessen interessant, auch weil er sich verändert hat. Es gibt diesen formellen Trilog und den informellen Trilog. Aber ich würde auch mal sagen, wir lassen ihn weg und fordern stattdessen unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen auf, gute Darstellungen des formellen und informellen Trilogs, die nicht in der Wikipedia stehen, meine Lieben, an uns zu senden und uns zu sagen, ob wir das noch machen wollen. In den Kommentaren bei chaosradio.de. Wie wäre das? Wäre das eine schlaue Idee?
Auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht auch noch eine weitere Sache. Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, dass in Österreich das Parlament eine bündende Entscheidung treffen kann zu den Fahnen durch den Rat. Das Spannende ist, jetzt komme ich wieder mit Lieblingsartikeln, nach Artikel 23 des Grundgesetzes kann der Deutsche Bundestag auch zwar eine nicht bündende, aber eine Weisung zu Verhalten oder zu Abstimmungsverhalten im Rat machen. Da kann man sich auch politisch positionieren. Und das ist bisher noch nicht geschehen. Das ist bei der aktuellen Positionierung der Bundesregierung, das kann man vielleicht auch noch mal kurz beleuchten. Die Bundesregierung hat sich positioniert, teilweise ganz gut im Hinblick auf den Schutz von verschütteter Kommunikation.
Teilweise sehr deutlich. Wenn man mal die Minister nennen, die hier zu nennen sind, ist einmal Wissing und einmal Buschmann. Also Buschmann als Justizminister von der FDP und Wissing als Digitalminister, wie sie jetzt auch immer sagen. Auch von der FDP, die haben das schon sehr deutlich eräußert.
Die haben sich sehr deutlich geäußert.
Was ist denn mit unserer Innenministerin von der SPD?
Also es ist ja auch total spannend, dass die Sachverständige in der Anhörung, die Sachverständige der SPD in der Anhörung im Bundes-, im Digitalausschuss sehr stark...
Ja, ich hau mir jetzt, mach keinen Insider, sag, wer das war.
Also ich wurde von der SPD in den Digitalausschuss geladen als Expertin zu dem Thema Chatkontrolle. Und ich habe da auch sehr deutlich unsere Positionen und meine Einschätzung dazu vorgetragen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein offener Konflikt in der SPD.
Ja, aber die Innenministerin hat in vielen digitalpolitischen Fragen offenen Konflikt in der SPD. Die ist die zerrissenste der Parteien von den drei, muss man schon deutlich sagen. Aber sie ist auch offenbar sehr wirkmächtig.
Um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, es ist halt total egal, was unsere Innenministerin macht. Das Parlament könnte trotzdem diese Artikel 23-Abstimmung mal anstoßen, um einfach den Druck ein bisschen zu erhöhen. Weil die Positionierung der Bundesregierung, die wir haben, ist ein Teil, auf den sie sich einigen konnten, ist sehr gut. Der andere Teil ist halt agree to disagree. Eine Positionierung wird irgendwie noch stattfinden. Deswegen verhalten wir uns dazu irgendwie.
Würde man nicht wieder generalisieren können, zu sagen, eigentlich sollte sich ein deutscher Parlament und andere europäische Parlamente häufiger direkt positionieren zu Gesetzgebungsvorhaben? Nö, wollen wir hier ein bisschen meter. Wir wollen mal ein bisschen ja, hm?
Also, ich, ich... Also, ja, ich glaube auch, vor allen Dingen ist es wichtig zu verstehen. Ich finde, manchmal fühlt sich ja die EU und auch das EU-Parlament sehr weit weg und sehr abstrakt an. Man muss aber auch immer sagen, und das kann ich auch nicht aufhören zu betonen, dass wir auch, ich sag mal, bei uns zu Hause mit unseren gewählten Vertreterinnen in der Regierung und im Bundestag auch schon eine Menge bewegen können. Und das muss man halt auch immer beachten. Gerade in Deutschland, Deutschland ist ein sehr, sehr mächtiges Land, wenn es um EU-Dinge kommt. Wir sind eines der größten Länder.
Wirtschaftsstark, den ganzen Länderleien.
Es gibt ja auch sozusagen, wenn im Rat, es gibt einen Voting-Calculator für den Rat und das geht ja nach prozentualem Bevölkerungsanteil der EU. Das heißt, wir haben natürlich einen relativ hohen Prozentanteil, deswegen fällt unsere Stimme auch relativ schwer ins Gewicht. Um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, ihr könnt halt auch, indem ihr eure Bundestagsabgeordneten kontaktiert, Einfluss auf EU-Gesetz zu nehmen. Und es wäre jetzt in dieser Chatkontrolle auch sehr, sehr angemessen, sich vielleicht auch einfach mal die Abgeordneten in eurem Wahlkreis vorzunehmen, die für euch im Bundestag sitzen und zu sagen so, Leute, wir sind überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit der Positionierung der Bundesregierung. Ihr seid unsere gewählten Vertreterinnen. Macht da was. Ihr könnt was machen.
Und wir haben diesmal ja ein Beispiel. Und wir haben auch gerade ein österreichisches Beispiel, weil der vielleicht immer noch, weil eben auch deutschsprachig ist, weil vielleicht auch am ehesten noch wahrgenommen wurde. Ich fand das ganz bemerkenswert. Es liegt jetzt aber schon Monate zurück, ich finde.
Wann haben wir das gemacht? Im Dezember oder so? Oder im Oktober? Nee, im Oktober. Und das ist auch das Interessante in Österreich, dass alle Parteien sich einzeln einig waren. Und die Einzigen, die dagegen gestimmt haben, waren sie Konservativen, aber nur, weil sie noch extremer dagegen vorgehen wollten.
Ich denke ja auch, dass bei uns eine Mehrheit gegen diese Vorschläge wäre. Ich glaube, die Informiertheit ist bei uns in Deutschland auch relativ groß, weil die Presse doch eben auch auf Deutsch viel berichtet hat. Also eine ist, was wir zum Ende hin sagen wollen. Man braucht sich nicht fürchten vor dieser EU. Auch da gibt es Prozesse, die kann man lernen, so wie wir heute viel wissen über parlamentarische Prozesse in der Bundesrepublik. Die kriegt man einfach mit. Teilweise kriegt man sie schon in der Schule gelehrt. Bei manchen Menschen, so finde ich, braucht man sich in der EU eigentlich nicht fürchten. Man muss es kennen, wenn man Einfluss nehmen will oder sich für manche interessiert. Aber man kann auch, wir haben kurz darüber gesprochen, man kann sich natürlich auch Institutionen zuwenden, die sich da kümmern. Edri wäre ein Beispiel. Wir werden vielleicht im Zuge des Podcasts Dicke Bretter noch zu anderen Organisationen kommen. Aber ich glaube, man muss sich hier nicht fürchten. Man muss sich aber auch informieren. Immer nur meckern über die EU, finde ich keinen guten Weg.
Ja, und ich glaube, dass auch irgendwie diese Frustration mit der EU teilweise dazu zustande kommt, weil man halt den fehlenden Blick hinter die Kulissen hat. Und dann manchmal versucht, an Punkten anzusetzen, wo ich halt dann auch ganz ehrlich sagen muss...
Das war nicht der gute Punkt.
Das war jetzt total frustrierend für dich. Und das ist total schade, weil du hast halt einen total wichtigen Punkt und auch inhaltlich total richtigen Punkt. Aber wenn du denen an, keine Ahnung, jetzt im Hinblick kurz vor einer Abstimmung in dem spezifischen Fachausschuss bei dem Abgeordneten untergebracht hättest, dann wärst du wahrscheinlich viel zufriedener da rausgegangen und hättest auch viel mehr Wirkmächtigkeit gehabt. Oder wenn du halt irgendwie vor der Abstimmung im Parlament mit deinem Parlamentarier gesprochen hättest oder zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt irgendwie eine Demo organisiert hättest oder so. Also ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch so wichtig, auch wenn das immer alles total erschlagend klingt, es ist am Ende kein Hexenwerk. Und wenn man es verstanden hat, dann kann man sich auch total gut einbringen, ohne dass man komplett frustriert sein muss von der ganzen Geschichte.
Also sich zu informieren, schallt ja sowieso nicht.
Man sollte eh mal wissen, wo man den Bohrer ansetzt, um die Dicken Bretter am Ende auch zu erledigen, um die Metapher mal bis zum Ende durchzureiten.
Wir hoffen, wir konnten motivieren dazu. Und wir wollen diese Reihe, Dicke Bretter, wie unser Podcast heißt, wir wollen die fortsetzen. Wollen wir schon verraten, unser nächstes Thema? Oder wollen wir geheim bleiben? Ich sehe schon, ja, wir bleiben total geheim. Ich kriege hier nur ein verbales Zeichen.
Der Rat der Dicke Bretter muss noch verhandeln. Drahtbericht folgt.
Okay, in der nächsten Reihenfolge ist wieder ein reguläres Chaosradio dran. Dann im Juli. Wissen wir aber auch noch nicht, was inhaltlich passiert. Also können wir noch nicht teasern. Wir bedanken uns jedenfalls jetzt schon. Wenn ihr Kommentare ins Blog packt und hoffen, dass wir euch gut informiert haben. Und dann bedanken wir uns nochmal bei Erdgeist. Und natürlich bei der Crew vom Chaosradio. Bei Erdgeist für die Musik und bei der Crew vom Chaosradio, die ja die Produktion übernimmt. Und auch nochmal bei Markus Richter, an dem wir die Einleitung sprechen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.